like when I set up that was the absolute
right time for me to do it because I
thought 7 10 years down the line I might
be in a completely different situation I
might you know have more
responsibilities than I did and I was
like if I set up now that long-term gain
is going to be there for me Hina Muny
the co-founder of life science Talent
partner after she successfully climbed
the ranks of a recruitment business and
became their top biller in January 2022
she decided to launch her very own
recruitment business with her co-founder
Chris in just two short years they've
grown the team to a team of six and
generated Circ 2 million in Revenue so
how did she do it I think they all call
it golden handcuffs cuz you're walking
away from a big fat book and you're
getting paid off that book regardless of
whether you Bill or not this is what
you're going to learn in this week's
episode how to overcome and manage
self-doubt when launching your own
business how to build a contract desk
entirely from scratch when you first
start out you're going to have to ask
the difficult questions because people
move quick people people find out
quickly and you've got to be on top of
it the secret to maintaining long-term
relationships with your contractors cuz
if you building those relationships with
the candidates ultimately they'll give
you the leads so those are your green
shoots the art of lead generation and
how to become world class at maximizing
information from your network let's get
into this week's episode Hena welcome to
the podcast thank you thank you for
having me on looking forward to this I
know so you just saying you've been told
by several people um your the things
that like you being on a podcast would
be would be interesting so yeah I have a
lot to say so let's see how it goes yeah
exactly and uh we got here because your
your co-founder said that you are one of
the the best contract recruiters he's
ever worked with could be true I mean he
went into business with me so yeah like
I think that says something yeah
absolutely and um yeah so we're we're
going to talk about your nearly six
years um in in the recruitment industry
what we're going to mainly focus on
today is for the last two you've been
building CHR Life Sciences with Chris
yeah did you work with each other at HRS
yes so funnny enough Chris actually
recruited me into recruitment okay nice
yeah so Chris is your like first manager
yeah so I had an interview with him and
our old founder M and they said you know
why do you want to do Recruitment and I
just sat there and I was like do you
know what I'll be honest it's not
something I thought of I wanted to go
into medical sales and I think
pharmaceutical recruitment gave me that
of impact on the industry that I wanted
and I went on to talk about that and
then I was like so it's like Chris is my
fairy
Godmother it made me memorable got me
the job so yeah so you worked at HRS for
nearly four years was one of their their
top uh billers there and you've always
been in contract which is why uh I said
to you right in terms of why Chris Dr me
a note is I've really tried to have a
push on having more contract Recruiters
on the pods cuz I've had a lot more per
recruiters um and then since you set up
C HR you did a retainer to start but
you've like been building the contract
book yeah right that's correct so just
to give people some highlights then so
let let me know if I get any any of this
wrong okay so uh uh in terms of like
before you started uh your own business
I think you shared to me that over the
three years that you were there overall
you made you did a million in profit in
three years across over the years in
three years and then by the time I left
it was probably a bit more yeah and then
I think I've got here 50k monthly was
that like your Peak yeah I'd say that
was my Peak um and then Rec award
contract recruit of the Year 2021 let's
go yeah won that cheers two years ago
though um still though pretty cool um
cool so there's some of the things
around HRS and then in terms of your own
business now with Chris um where we're
at is you're uh going to do this year
Circa 2 million uh in revenue and then
there's five of you in the business yeah
and I think you shared to me here um in
terms of way around you're around uh
year 2 contract bildings wise you've
written up around 500k yeah well it's
almost 600 now since you okay nice cool
all right so we're going to unpack this
journey that you've been on so let let's
start though I'd love to hear your take
on what what do you believe are the the
common characteristics and traits that
make up a successful contract recruiter
so for contract recruiters I feel like
Chris even still gives it to me he's
like oh contract recruiters are like
slimy car salesman and I'm like no we're
not like the good ones aren't so I think
the two things would have to be they've
got to be confident and they've got to
be humble because when you're building
out a contract desk and you're building
those connections people see through
they see through you they become your
friends and they're not going to like
you if you're arrogant they're not going
to like you if you are like that
typical I guess stereotypical recruiter
where you know people don't have a good
rep yeah so I think those are the two
main things you got to be confident in
that you go to events similar to how we
met I just went up to you I was like are
you hean and you like yeah that's what
you have to do you have to put yourself
out there and you've got to get
comfortable in the
uncomfortable I feel like I don't know
if you found this either when you was at
HRS or when you're hiring people now
sometimes people can have a hard time
being themsel in like a work
context how did you find that like was
it did you sort of was it quite natural
for you to like be your like authentic
self obviously you hear that word a lot
right so I don't know like how how did
you how did you find that cuz I think so
it definitely took me a bit a time like
if I think of when I first started in
recruitment I really like I don't know
it wasn't like a really natural voice I
was quite concerned about how I'd be
perceived yeah I think it comes down to
individuals I was really lucky that I
had a really good team when I was at HRS
like we all got along really well we
work well together and I'm someone who
can just be myself easily because I'm
kind of like well if you don't like like
it then that's on you and I think even
with my contractors I am pretty much
myself yeah but it comes down to
different people because we had one girl
who started um our first employee came
in obviously sitting with two directors
I'd hate for that to be me she came in
sat on her bag and she was nervous but
it takes time yes to build up to being
who you actually are but that's normal
in any job I think I think it's getting
that fine balance between showing who
you are but also having that
professional side as well why do you
think you're it's quite easy for you to
not be like what you just said there
isn't common for everyone in terms of
like if if you don't like who I am then
that's that's fine I think a lot of
people wor about other people's opinions
like where where's that come from I
think it comes with age I'm not that old
but but I so I used to be really shy
like yep I wouldn't order something in a
restaurant I would be sh yeah I would
you wouldn't order something in a
restaurant so who would order stuff at
you Mom and Dad wow brother sister
friends I would not think that yeah I
was such a shy girl and then then yeah I
got my first job at 14 and it was at
Kumon so it's like maths in English and
I was put on the front desk so doing
that I had to speak to parents kids
every Saturday morning every Monday
evening and it just changed me and I
think from that young age working and
putting yourself in situations you don't
like you just have to be I hate it but
people say be unapologetically yourself
it's so cringe but it's true like in
recruitment cuz you spend so much of
your time at work going to events
speaking to people it's long hours you
can't fake it like people say fake it
till we make it don't do that that's the
worst thing you can do be
yourself wow I can't that's I would not
imagine you to say that you're shy I was
such a shy C really yeah I don't know
what happened did not changeed no that
that's awesome um so let like let's talk
about let's get into this like you
obviously I want to talk about the the
last two years right uh mainly but I
guess how how did you feel going into
knowing that you CU I feel like the
really interesting about contract
recruitment I was just interviewing
someone that's in perm recruitment you
go into the next year and you're back to
zero right which is which is is that's
hard it's it's like part of the process
but with contract recruitment there's a
lot to to walk away from if you leave
the company you work for you've watched
your absolute sucks off to get to your
get your contract back to where it is
and for you to then leave it's like [__]
that like this even more to like leave
right so you and Chris starting this
business you you had to leave what you
built you had to leave you knew how much
money was making each month no doubt
like it was really challenging to get to
where it where where it got to like I've
learned about you you really take your
relationship seriously so you also know
you're going to have to not be able to
speak to these people anymore so like
just talk to me about you know
particularly as a contract recruiter
starting a recruitment business business
like what what was going through your
mind going into those first early months
cuz like you basically had to start from
from zero which you wouldn't have for
the four years and and when you started
building things up right yeah I think
they all call it golden handcuffs CU
you're walking away from a big fat book
and you're getting paid off that book
regardless of whether you Bill or not
and that was hard like it was like I'm
walking away from this I've taken off
like the safety blanket I'm not going to
be able to speak to the people that I
speak to every day for 6 months it was
like a breakup but with like a hundred
different people cuz like you're so used
to talking to them and like they send
you pictures of their grandkids like
you're always messaging you're always on
the phone like I remember one time
contract called me at 8:00 p.m. I was
like what's happened is someone dying
why is he calling me turns out I just
wanted to chat I was like okay cool and
it's like taking that away for six
months was so so difficult and I also
remember like it was between Christmas
and New Year um I messaged Chris at like
3:00 a.m. and I was like I was like I
can't do this I was like cuz it's such a
big step that you've got to take but the
thing that I had like the faith in was
my relationships and I thought these
first six months actually it's not a bad
thing because what I did was went out to
another Market built that out and that's
benefited us today and then once those
six months are over everyone's buzzing
to hear from you like I remember I was
just back to back with calls like
nonstop for like two three weeks just
people wanting to know where I've been
What I've Done unfortunately all i' done
was
work nothing exciting but they were so
engaged engaged in the journey and I
think I mentioned to you before like
those relationships that you build so
one of the first ever contractors I met
I met him at Kings Cross station for a
coffee no idea what he looked like no
picture on LinkedIn his WhatsApp picture
was Tasmania I was like I don't
know going to happen met him loveliest
guy ever still meet up with him for
copies now and he introduced us to one
of our biggest clients so it's those
relationships that you're not going to
see the benefit of straight away but you
will get there and you'll build it but
you've got to have that genuine desire
to build those relationships build out
your Market because if you do it well
then you're laughing what was going
through your mind at 3:00 a.m. that made
you send that message like what was you
most fearful of because I think this is
good for people to know like who are in
contract Recruitment and you know a lot
of people you can do these interesting
things now on if you listen to the
podcast on Spotify I can do like polls
and one of the polls I did recently was
um how how many of you have thought
about setting up on your own yeah and a
lot people voted yeah I think about it a
lot and I feel like when you're in
contract as we said there's a lot more
to walk away from so what what was it
that you was really fearful of was it
fearful of of failing was it fearful of
being do you did you back yourself to
like build up the the book again what
what was you really fearful of so I had
another offer and it was for a um to be
employed yeah be employed executive
Search company building out their
contract function cuz that's what will
make them profitable when they want to
sell and it was a fat offer they'll give
me a guarantee for 6 months big juicy
one yeah it was amazing and I was like
I'm walking away to literally go to
nothing but then Chris sort of put it to
me he was like you're building out a
contract function for someone else why
wouldn't you want to do it for yourself
he's like you know you can do it um and
I think it was that I think they call it
imposter syndrome where I'm kind of like
oh no can't do it not good enough and
it's just having that faith and like
belief in yourself because you can do it
you've got the relationships you've got
the KN how you've got the methodology
you need to apply it to a new market for
the first six months months and then
from there build it back up
yeah fair enough oh yeah I forgot you
said yeah there's another offer on the
table yeah that must have been uh yeah
it was I was kind of at the point where
I was like look when I left I was what
25 didn't have like a husband didn't
have a kid had a mortgage but it it was
fine like I was like the worst thing
that's going to happen is I'm going to
set up and we fail then I just find
another job yeah that I was going to say
like I found it really useful no
scenario just to genuinely ask really
think about what is the worst case
scenario and when you have the skill set
that you do the worst case scenario is
you go back to the fatter offer and and
do that for somebody else yeah exactly
and I thought that was like when I set
up that was the absolute right time for
me to do it because I thought you know
five seven 10 years down the line I
might be in a completely different
situation I might you know have more
responsibilities than I did and I was
like if I set up now that long-term gain
is going to be there for me yeah and I
think we're doing okay nice so I know I
know we didn't want to talk about the
the 90day plan right which I'm not going
to ask
you but obviously I think I think people
would want to know like how you approach
those first six months because of course
you would have loved to just yeah be
able to that's why we have covenants
right people need to protect their
business so yeah like how how did you go
about that was it straight to right who
can I get on the phone to who can I
start building relationships with like
how did you approach those first uh
couple of months so in the UK I've got
quite quite a specific market so it was
QP so that's a qualified person they
essentially release a drug to Market to
say that it's safe in literal layman's
terms I thought that's what you did
previously sorry yeah so that's what I
was doing doing it again now and I
thought that look up UK can't touch that
because everyone I've worked with is
like they're the contractors to be in
touch with it's like so can't do that at
all so I thought where's logical for me
to look at so I looked at Island because
I was like no language barrier no time
difference and the method in terms of
recruitment is the same like it's all
contract you've got the professionals
and you know what they need to do so I
was like let me go to Ireland let me
build that out but then I was like at
the same time do risk it if the Irish QP
Market is rubbish let me look at
different areas so I stupidly looked at
I did a bit in Belgium did a bit in
Germany and I think if one thing if I
could go back and change something I
would have just stuck to Ireland
completely just committed to that yeah I
think they say in Wild mile deep that's
what I would have done I think I spread
myself too thinly and I think that's the
big why do you think you did that
panicking just kind of like if if this
Market doesn't work out I need like
backup but it did work out and I should
have had more belief in myself but at
the same time I think I've learned a lot
from that how long would you like
Curious then how long would you cuz I'm
sure you will help future people in your
team think about this but like how long
would you give a market from a contract
terms in terms of for you to feel like
I've giving this if you're doing like
the basics right the thing I'm doing the
the things I need to do right how long
would you typically uh give it to go you
know what we've really given that market
a crack maybe it wasn't what we thought
it was what are your thoughts on that
we're like going to delve into a 90day
planet you know just in terms of like
what like cuz you said you would have
you would have gone to other places
because you might not been seeing the
things that you thought you would have
been seeing by that time so I'm just
curious like from looking back or
whatever how long do you think is a fair
amount of time to go you know what I've
really given that market a go cuz you
could leave too early you could like is
what you're saying you could leave on
like the cast of a deal that's what I'm
saying yeah I think so with me what I
would do first is they always say
candidate is King and I truly or queen
CU got politically correct course um but
your candidate is going to give you
everything so I would spend a good one
two months speaking to the candidate is
getting to know them and I said to the
guy that I'm training at the moment
every call you have with the candidate
you've got to come up with a fun fact
for them what sorry a fun fact a fun
fact yeah that's a new one so we're not
we're not we're not lead like I don't
want leads I want fun facts no it's true
I was like I want a fun fact because no
someone called you and they wanted to
delete straight away you're not going to
give it to them I don't know you I don't
trust you like who are you yeah whereas
if you get a fun fact from them that's
something that you can call them back
and you can ask them about it what could
what could the fun fact be then well the
first guy I got them to call I was like
call this guy I was like I know the fun
fact about him that he'll tell you find
it out fun fact was on a Wednesday
afternoon and Saturday mornings he
trains
karate and I knew that I knew that he
the guy was in my Consultants market and
I was like you need to find out what it
is next time you called him oh how was
karate last night and building that and
just finding something really random
that other people don't care about but
the individual is actually passionate
about themselves helps you stand out
because it shows you care about them as
a person because we are all human we
don't want to be treated like just
another candidate on a system who's got
a few buzzwords on the CV yeah so I'd
say yeah build out the candidat side
speak to them for a good few months that
will help you get your leads that I'd
say most of my leads now are generated
from my candidates they just call me up
and they say oh I'm Contracting here
like loads of candidates to speak to
I've never placed but they give me the
leads they bring the business in because
it's that relationship that you've got
and people want to help people yeah but
people that they trust so it's going
back to that whole humble piece so so so
one two months really commit to the
candidates as you said yeah and then
what would be some of the like green
shoots that you'd expect to see is it is
the main thing that I should be looking
at is the amount of leads that I'm
getting in terms of like projects and
things that are going on that it make me
feel like right there there's definitely
some Traction in this market or there's
things that that's happening that is
making me feel better about giving it
another two months yeah cuz if you're
building those relationships with the
candidates ultimately they'll give you
the leads so those are your green shoots
you find out a lead you contact the
company you get the roll on you speak to
more candidates they're like okay this
girl or guy knows what they're talking
about because they know that that
project is happening there from that you
know you do your classic recruitment
okay so exposing all my secrets here
every everyone it's so good okay so I've
got this Ro here they're like I'm not
interested I'm like why aren't you
interested oh because I've got another
project I'm in interviewing for what's
that and you just build it out from
there that gives you a new lead and it's
just that cyclical thing and I think
with the thing with contract is it's
very much up and down buoyant things can
happen literally overnight I remember a
few years ago before the Christmas party
got a new job on had to deliver the
candidate the offer literally as we were
leaving really yeah literally massive
deal like contract's mad like that isn't
it cuz like if you didn't if you didn't
take action on that someone else could
have got if it wasn't exclusive like you
have to [__] just be on it for the
next like 48 Hours basically literally
and that's why I hate taking annual
leave like took a day off my birthday
Chris posts new consultant Ro available
I literally called him up I was like
what are you doing he was like it's your
birthday they have a day off I was like
honestly get
lost no um is that is that the case
though you've got like if you if you get
given uh a contract role like do you
literally have to be on it for 48 hours
like I'd say 24 if I'm honest really so
in 24 hours what would what would you
want to where would you want to be in
terms of like sent over fre contractors
for them to meet yeah yeah it would be a
question of I tried to do it on the so
let's say I had a call after this new
contract role I'd expect to have three
to five CVS by the end of the day to the
client yeah CU that shows that you know
who to call you're in with the network
and then what I'd spend the rest of so
first 24 hours get the profiles that are
going to go to the client next 24 hours
closing off the rest of the market
because people move quick people find
out quickly and you've got to be on top
of it yeah you've got to always yeah
just close off everyone that you can
that is a matter thing about Contracting
that yeah it just you got be but I'm
impatience I love contract I don't think
I could do perm yeah too much trating
because on the flip side if you get a
lead and you know uh yeah you find out
who the company is how long would you
attempt to like action that lead or like
try and get a hold of them before you
like stop trying to action it if you get
what I mean cuz I think there's also a
bit of a Time window there right cuz you
know how quickly people can move yes so
if you just found found out so and so
there's a there's a contract project
over here or they're hiring contractors
yeah and then you're trying to get hold
of them are you giving it like 48 hours
trying to be all over it and then you're
following up or do you know what I mean
do you have like a a window on that
where you're like this is probably being
filled I'm still going to try and get a
hold of that I don't know so I would so
what I would do is find another lead
from a candidate straight away I'd call
the next best person I know for that job
and say have you been called about this
role because I know my competitors
they're amazing like there's one guy
who's doing really well um and I know he
would have called that person if he's on
that job so I would call the next best
person see if they've been called and
then after that I would call the client
and I'd say I've got you someone who is
what you're looking for can solve this
problem that you yeah and that's yeah
that's hard work it that's a great
little tip to be fair thank
you yeah rather than yeah but do you
think there is a bit of a cuz I'm I'm
just like probing you about it because I
do feel like it's definitely different
to perm obviously but because of the way
that you're what the way that you
operate there's got to be like a shelf
life of like how long that LE is like do
you know what I mean like hot for
example it's like a a much shorter
window obious absolutely yeah yeah but
then at the same time you get a contract
role so we had someone interview five
weeks ago offer came through this week
oh yeah mov a lot more quicker now well
I think someone went off and then there
was like some sort of half term like an
extended one for one of the H manager's
kids right and things just got delayed
the site's got some other issues they're
moving licenses about and stuff like
that offer came through and I'm like
that's too late because you know how
quickly contract moves and T gu was like
yeah probably gone but we want to offer
him and I'm like you've got to move
quicker MH but you be surprised that my
first ever 360 deal took a good few
months to come in did it and I was like
this isn't contract I was like what am I
doing but it was yeah it was a contract
role just took months because client had
different terms that they wanted us to
sign how long did it take to do your
first 360 contract deal that was when
you had your own business when I when
you had your own obviously in the first
six months oh sorry yes the first deal
was a retainer three months in three
months in yeah but that I got from a
lead because they wanted a consultant
and then you was doing that was per that
was yeah that was perm smashing some
perm deals yeah let's go it's got to be
done so how long they take you to do
your first contract deal then four
months four months yeah Fair same Cent I
was like same client that's interesting
same client um basically s than the
retainer dream and I was like look what
you want you want it so soon let's put a
contractor in place because they can
also help sort of like navigate and
guide what you're looking for because I
think they were a bit onshore we'll get
back to the episode in just one minute
but today I'm excited to talk to you
about one of our partners Firefish the
recruitment CRM that accelerates
datadriven growth being able to
Benchmark your agency's performance
against others in your industry has
always been impossible until now our
partners at Firefish have just recently
released their IND ly benchmarking
dashboards taking Data Insights to the
next level by enabling you to Benchmark
your own performance your recruiters and
team performance against others within
your sector the benchmarking dashboards
are built on anonymized placement sales
and kpi data so Firefish users can get a
monthly snapshot of their agency's
performance benchmarks against their
peers in seconds if you want to learn
more about benchmarking dashboards or
find out how Firefish can support your
company's growth this year they very car
offered our community the recruitment
mentals podcast a special offer that's
going to save you thousands of pounds
now this offer is only available until
March the 31st so you can click the link
in the show description or you can head
to Firefish software.com
slrm nice let me ask you this then like
what I continue to learn in these
conversations is you hear you hear this
term lead so much in contract right and
like as soon if I start a if I start a
job in your in your team like I'm sure
I'm going to hear that word lead
multiple times in my first week so like
people will be drilled on this so so
early so people are aware that they need
to get leads but I'd love to just hear
your take on like when Hena first
started how did your cool sound when you
wasn't maybe very good at getting leads
compared to like how they s sound now
when you're more effective of getting
leads cuz I think that you know that's
like a skill to get leads right you're
talking about someone isn't just going
to give you the leads I want you to find
out a fun fact about them so what did
your like contract to call sound like
when maybe you feel like you wasn't that
good at getting leads and then what do
they sound like when you're probably
more effective at doing it yeah all I
got from that is you want to work for
CHR come in week one just Hammer the
word Leon to you yeah no so I think in
the first instance it can be awkward
because they don't know you you don't
know them and that's where that whole
fun fact thing comes into place and I
think I think when you first start out
you're going to have to ask the
difficult questions but at the same time
when you're looking for leads they can
be anything so they can be he can you
know you can speak to someone and they
can say oh well know X person's leaving
y company they're my best mate um or my
contracts not being extended here
because they're looking for a perm and
then that's obviously a perm lead that
you can pass over you can a lead can be
built from anything and I think any good
call you have even if it is the first
one you will find out something whether
that's finding out that oh I've just
left this company you then know that
that company take contractors so that
puts you in an excellent position to
contact that company say I know you take
contractors I'm a contract specialist
how do you take them do you take them
directly do you take them through
agencies how can I position myself to be
the next person you call when you need
another contractor because I'm working
with EXC candidate who's just left you
and I know that you think he's good
because you wanted to extend him but you
couldn't because of
XYZ so I think anything can be used as
part of like your business development
yeah because it's just so important to
try and draw that information out but
not do it in a like a direct way like
you've got to be not s about it but
you've got to do it in a way that people
want to open up to you so that's the
that's the difference
yeah how does it sound then at the start
is it just like I'm liter Going H where
have you interviewed oh I don't I don't
think I do that at the start at the
start though like you said it's a bit
like in a bit like a bit awkward like
what how is that how these calls end up
sounding it's like oh like where are you
interviewing or like do you mind telling
me where you've uh your friend has
interviewed or like do you know what I
mean I'll probably more go down if I was
new I would probably go blah blah blah
you know small talk and then I'll
present them with if I'm working a job
I'll present them with the job right and
then if they say no I'd say okay why not
and then they might say cuz I've got two
other applications that I've made so
like okay so how does that compare to
what I'm showing you and they might say
okay well the one that I'm interviewing
for is 10 miles down the road from where
I live and um I can work from home and
then what You' do is you then look at
that candidate and you'd see okay where
do they live what's 10 miles away from
them map out on a map all the companies
that fit that
parameter and then you'll call every
single company that fits into that
location and you'd say do you need
someone I've got someone so it'll be not
so direct you can be direct it works for
a lot of people
yeah like it's just not my style to be
like Brash about it and be like where
you interviewing H give me your leads
because people aren't stupid they know
what you're doing they know you're a of
course exactly um I Was preparing with
um like what we did the other day but
with uh this guy uh David on um uh for a
training session on Marti the co call to
like present your contract solution yeah
he he's felt like in his the most common
objection that you run into as you were
talking about like calling a business
stuff and I really like the way that you
spoke about that but he said the most
common objection that he finds that
contract recruits run into is we don't
use
Freelancers oh has that been your
experience or not not so much but I
think that's really Market specific um
yeah Fair our Market is heavily reliant
on contractors really yeah because our
contractors are either brought in to
solve a problem or to build something
new or even just maybe like a little
intermediary kind of person but there's
always that need some companies you're
right they won't use a contractor but
it's also then addressing the issue of
okay well how long will you look for a
permanent person because if there's like
a skills shortage or something you're
going to have to consider something and
it's like okay well if you're not going
to consider a contractor are you then
going to promote from within and then if
they say yes be like okay well what
about the Gap that that person's then
leaving and then again that's sort of
pushing in your perm solution cuz I
think a lot of people sort of miss out
on cross selling as well there's so many
opportunities that come from that and I
think that's something that Chris and I
do quite well like we compliment each
other's work and that's what we're
building out in our teams like cross
selling is so so important yeah no he he
sort of he sort of shares exactly what
you're talking about where it's like you
have to you have to ask like the the why
of what and how cuz then that that can
lead to the information that you just
said exactly what you just went through
then it's like also like how how how
you're going to approach like you still
need that need right now so like how you
going to approach dealing with that
issue and then they say well we've got
someone internally dealing with it at
the moment they're a bit stretch what
it's like okay well what like like you
just said and then that can lead to
different things right yeah that that's
interesting um so when the six months
hit then is it just straight on WhatsApp
like it was team I'm back what are you
saying like did you just get straight
back to it yeah it was a LinkedIn post
of my laptop in Mom and Dad's Garden was
a sunny day and it was just the Classic
hi everyone um but good to connect with
everyone again and then I put a little
calendly link think can book in time and
that just went wild comments messages
and what was the objective of these
calls just like just literally just
literally catching up just seeing how
are you how's the family what have you
been up to um yeah what's new more on
the personal side because to be honest I
wasn't expecting to get like loads of
leads and stuff like it was it was
summer like not that much happens and I
just have that genuine like friendship
with my contractors to want to know what
they've been up to and what they've done
in the last six months
why is that so important to
you that's a horrible question why no
I'm just curious cuz like I don't know
how to answer it it's I've had people on
I've had people on before where like
they they like really passionate about
that I'm just curious like why that's so
important I think it's like we spoke
about before like that human
connection and I think the worst thing
for me is letting someone down okay like
whether that's like my mom dad brother
sister Chris business like anyone like
any of my friends or anything like that
I I don't want to let people down and I
think going into a contract Market
you're going to put your all in to make
things happen for your candidates and if
you don't have that sort of desire to
help them because ultimately it's their
liveliness that you're looking after
because if they're not in a contract
they're not working they can't pay for
their holidays and stuff like that so I
just feel like a bit I don't know just a
bit of like responsibility I guess in
terms of I want to help my friends
out like yeah it's it's a hard question
but it's just kind of I don't know I
guess it's how I am like with my friends
like I'll put everything into my
friendships because that's something
that's important to me how do you keep
on top of it all that that's what I also
find baffling about contracts like cuz
that at your Peak HRS or now whatever
like how how many Runners did you have
at one point I had 28 at Point how do
you keep on top of that um cuz you got
to stay in touch with these people right
like is it a weekly thing is it a
bi-weekly thing is it just a WhatsApp
message what we saying um when I was at
HRS it was more just telephone calls
yeah um just catching up with them every
week just to see how it's going but a
lot of the time it wouldn't be about the
contract it would just be like oh what
have you been up to this week how's your
weekend how's the dog right stuff like
that um now I find it difficult because
I don't I don't speak to my contractors
as much as I'd want to because I'm also
running a business and that's one thing
that I find sort of like the hardest
it's like I can't dedicate that time to
always speaking to them because I'm also
like training people doing business
stuff and I think that that's yeah
that's probably the hardest part like
you feel like You' you're missing out
but at the same time like you're missing
out yeah just on chats and like stuff
like get pH on what the contractors are
up to yeah literally um like I spoke to
my contractor yesterday I hadn't spoken
to him in like two three weeks and
normally we speak like every week or
every other week at least I was like
what's going on he said oh he's I'm just
busy I was just fluffing the Christmas
tree I was okay you do you but it's just
like it's hard to do everything yeah um
secur and how much if you're a contract
recruiter how much of your week if we to
do like percentage how much of your week
do you think should be spent like
speaking to your existing contracts did
you think depends how many you've got um
I think if you if if you're starting out
your career and you've got five
contractors you should put in your diary
to call them I don't know like every
Tuesday afternoon or every Friday
afternoon or something like that like it
should be there they should know that
they're going to get a call from you
every week just to check in but saying
that some contractors don't like it
really yeah I had one of my first
placements over in Island um called him
when he started and sort of checked in
with him and then he was like why did
you keep calling me he didn't say that
he was like oh I'm I'm doing really well
but if I need something I'll I'll call
you and then I explained to him he was
oh that's really nice he's like he's
he's B old he was like I've never had
this before and I was like oh okay
that's that's strange because I would
always check check in he's like no I
appreciate it but like don't worry I
think he thought that I was stressed
about him cuz the place he was at was
challenging um that is also lesson right
cuz like you it is also important to
know and understand how people like to
be communicated with exactly because not
everyone wants to chat to me every week
I don't blame
them but at least you you know when
you've got your checking points you know
how to communicate some of them
literally just like like I've got
WhatsApp group chats with some of my
contractors like just random stuff gets
sent in there like what's your WhatsApp
group called
it's called secondary
Squad I thought that might have been an
interesting name there secondary Squad
the reason for that is cuz I placed a
group of them at a company before yeah
and they made their own WhatsApp group
right and you what felt left out so yeah
I felt left out because that happened
once I'd left and I was in my
restrictive covenants yeah and then a
couple of them stopped Contracting so
then I made a new one with the
contractors right um we're actually
going aaring in a couple of weeks I'm
buzzing for it how much do you invest in
contractor care obvious you're talking
about now time but like as a now you're
as a business these are the sort of
decisions and money that you can put
into right contractor care cuz that's
also an important thing right yeah oh
absolutely um like at Christmas time
I'll take all my contractors out um just
for like an activity or a meal or
something like that and then throughout
the year I'll try and see them like at
probably like halfway through their
contract or something like that depends
on location yeah I'm lucky that a few of
mine are London Bas at the moment
going up to Nottingham on Monday for a
contract to dinner um but I think that's
that stuff's invaluable because you look
at the margins what they're making you
like if you're not being encouraged to
go and meet your contractors and
reinvesting some of that profit into
those types of things you have to it
just shows that you actually care about
them because you'd be surprised like
some people aren't allowed to go meet
their contractors I've been lucky that
I've been in businesses where it's
always encouraged not allowed yeah I
know I was interview someone and they
were like yeah we don't we don't do that
and I was if not why not like you've got
to put that effort in to get the returns
because when they finish that contract
who are they going to come to for the
next contract they're going to come to
you and if they hear about something
they'll let you
know so what are some of the like we've
spoken a lot already you just touching
on it there but we've spoken a lot
around Hena as the contract recruiter
and you know how you've gone about your
craft what are some of the the mindset
shifts that you've had to have since
having this business with Chris cuz it
is a different mindset like it's a
different responsibility like yes of
course you have to generate Revenue
particularly with where you are on your
business Journey like you and Chris have
to be generating a revenue or impacting
um Revenue like yeah how have you had to
how how have you had to change your your
mindset towards being now you're a
co-founder of a of a business yeah I
think so at HRS I had a period where I
didn't have a manager um and I think
that really helped me because it made me
look at and I was coached quite well in
terms of it made me look at you know how
much money am I risking to get like a
return so it made me look at margins and
things like that and making sure that
it's appropriate because now that I'm a
business owner um like my contractors
are on big money they're on like ,000
pound a day plus and when we started I
certainly couldn't afford to pay that to
them every week so we had like a funding
partner who did that for us um now we
use Rays I don't know if you know them
but they're sort of another funding
partner and what they do is they mirror
what we want really well like absolutely
fantastic and stuff like that like
making those decisions because now I've
got to factor in that I've got to pay
like a a charge to them so the way I
think of it is okay so I've got to pay
that off the back of every invoice
that's generated but I see that as like
a service charge so like instead of
paying someone to come in write the
contract see the time sheets I I
consider it like that and you've also
got to think about every single decision
so if you're looking at a new software
or um you know something for the staff
or something like that you've got to
think okay so what will what will this
cost and what will the returns be
because ultimately you're a business and
you've got to survive and it's having
that sort of like entrepreneurial
mindset where you've got to think what's
the impact of you know getting this in
or something like that we'll get back to
the episode in just one minute but today
I'm excited to talk to you about one of
our partners sourcewell the
industry-leading business development
and head hunting platform at the end of
last year sourcewell released an
exciting new feature the platform's very
own live feed being honest with you this
feature has been one of my favorites
today
because it tells you exactly who's
engaging with your Outreach in real time
this means you can easily tell which
lead is hot and which is not so you can
connect with the right people at the
right time to Skyrocket your engagement
you can actually hear from one of our
mentors and 2023 panelists Amber Penrose
on how she's achieved instant results
with sell's new feature live feed the
sourcewell livess feature has enabled me
to become a secret little stalker and to
contact my ideal customer profile whilst
they're at their desks and especially
for someone like me who works in biotech
where computer time understandably for a
lot of scientists just isn't prevalent
this has been a huge help and for
example a biotech vice president of HR
who I have been politely pastoring for
what feels like my entire life finally
picked up the phone to me because I cold
called her after she clicked on my email
four times in a row which sourcewell
kindly had let me know to the point
where she actually giggled during my
cold call opener and responded with are
you in the office watching me and
despite That Awkward encounter we're now
working on a retain project with them in
Boston and that wouldn't have been
possible if it weren't for source whell
as you can see source whell is a great
tool for driving better engagement more
meetings and high Revenue if you're
looking for a Competitive Edge in 2024
then sourcewell could be for you you can
book a demo with sourcewell and mention
the recruitment mentors podcast to enjoy
an extra 50 phone and 50 email credits
per user and this exclusive offer for
this community is going to save you
Circa £500 or more and is only going to
be available until March the 31st so
click the link in the show notes or you
can go directly to source.com
slemo so if you're listening to this and
you're you may have aspirations to have
your own business like what I take from
that is like really try and be
intentional about being in the rooms and
ation that you experienced by accident
it seems where you didn't have a manager
for a bit and then you got exposed to
these things that's actually ended up
being really helpful cuz you're actually
learning to understand the commercials
and how HRS um you know make their money
or how it's all calculated rather than
just when you're an employee you just
care about the the number that you got
on the board and like when you're
getting paid right you're not really
thinking about ex those sorts of things
ex yeah you got to think about what's
the impact like am I risking ,000 pounds
a day to only get like1 pound back
that's not going to be worth it because
if your client goes bused and they don't
pay you then now what and you've got to
think about it like logically you've got
to think what's going to happen if
someone doesn't pay like you've always
got to think worst case because if
you're thinking about like obviously
don't be negative all the time but if
you're thinking about the worst case
that what could happen then it allows
you to sort of like future proof
yourself how have you and like Chris
being your manager or you being
employees is different to being
co-founders so Chris was my permanent
counterpart so we did the same markets
yeah so we worked quite closely together
then um and now in terms of like the
business what he tends to do is more
sort of like the operational side of
things um so like the contracts pay
rolles things like that and then I'm
probably more sort of like sales
director so I do like the training and
all that sort of things for the stuff
and was that quite natural for you to
end up both doing that or did you like
have a intentional conversation about
these are the things that I'm going to
really focus on or um well Chris has got
a lot more experience than I do um he's
probably going to listen to this I think
I'm calling him old which I probably am
um but yeah he's got a bit more
experience than I do so like when it
comes down to sort of like things like
hiring and things like that like it was
just natural that he took the lead on
that right um and I think that he's more
so he probably was more commercially
aware because he was a manager at old
place and things like that but it was
just natural in terms of we looked at
like what do you enjoy what do I enjoy
and because we're all best friends um we
get along so well and you can just have
those upfront conversations
of like you're not going to agree on
everything yeah I'll be like Chris why
and he'll obviously have to explain it
but you're not going to be in complete
Synergy all the time but it's about how
you deal with those things that happen
like if you don't agree on something
what how are you going to solve it but I
think I wouldn't have been able to do
this without having Chris like I
wouldn't have been able to sit up alone
he's literally been like my backbone or
right arm whatever the saying is so
friendship still strong yeah best
friends best friends
love that that's awesome I think you
know I set up my business on my own and
like there is is just completely like
different challenges like setting up
with someone else again that can come
with challenges right you can butt heads
and whatever but I do think I'm sure you
experien this like now but like when you
despite how close you are of your like
friends or your family they don't truly
know like how you're feeling or what
you're going through whereas Chris he he
is in the same shoes as you yeah
absolutely like he can truly relate and
understand CU you're both facing the
challenges head on whereas when you're
telling your mom about what you do and
why you might be a bit stressed and what
the challenges are she might make you
feel really listen but you know she
truly truly doesn't understand yeah
she'll be like it's all right it'll be
fine and it's like well it's not fine
but no I think they say it's Lonely at
the Top but with a clf Founder you're
not going to be lonely because like you
say he's walking the same path and it's
like especially at the start when we
weren't bilding what we were used to
like we weren't earning what we used to
that's difficult cuz you used to like a
c lifestyle and then all of a sudden
that's Stripped Away um you've got to
yeah it's it's so difficult cuz also
like even with friends I love my friends
but sometimes some of them are like oh
but you can just take a day off because
it's your own business or you can go in
whenever you want but it's like when
it's your own business that's when you
put in even more work and even more time
because like you like it's your
child my best friend's just had a kid
I'm like that's literally how I feel
about my business like I would do
anything for it yeah no that that's
awesome love that what um so you
mentioned there what have been some of
the the challenges and on this journey
so far that you least expected I think
the hiring piece cuz I wasn't always
harder than people think yeah like I was
in interviews previously at my old
company at HRS but I was never in charge
of like bringing the people in so we
probably spoken to like well over a 100
people in terms of interviewing like we
started hiring um over a year ago now
but the process was a lot longer than we
thought because we've got such a
specific vision and what we want and are
values are like important to us not
everyone says that but we're going to
hire people who mirror what our vision
is and it's difficult to find people who
buy into that because like I've said
it's Chris I'm like no one will care as
much about this business as we do and we
can't expect that from anyone because
it's not theirs they've not been there
from the start what you can do is get
people who want to align with you and
have that impact and I think it's also
sort of making sure that you're hiring
the right people in because that's
something that if especially when you're
so small if someone's not aligned to
what you're doing then that's going to
have a huge impact on the team yeah I
mean the first person I had I had to let
go oh it's hard
Rip but it's it's I've had to let two
people go so far on my journey but it is
true particularly obviously you're five
people right so I'm four including me
when I think what I love what you just
said there cuz not sometimes even
though the things that you just said
around like we can't expect them to care
about the business as much as we care
about it that's so the right thing but
you can often feel like when you're in a
small business like why won't they just
like just put in just a bit more effort
or whatever but you can't like you said
you can't it's not it's not their
business right but sometimes you can
have those expectations but when it is
when you are a small
size you can really pick up on quickly
when someone's like not right or that
they it's a net negative of like what
they're doing to like the energy and and
the group yeah exactly and you got you
got to take action on that yeah I
learned that from the first one it went
on for too long and then the the second
person it was people interview different
when you higher than it but like you've
got to Pro I feel like at all cost
particularly at the early stage You' got
to protect your culture at all costs you
just have to it's the right thingly cuz
also it's not just that it's like you're
paying for them to be with you and if
they're not aligning to what you want so
we've had two people that haven't worked
out first one was honestly a great guy
but he was quite young and then he
realized sales isn't for him which is
fine and then the second one was someone
who's experience
but if they kind of aren't aligned to
what you want and doing things how you
want them like without sounding spoiled
but it's my business like we need that's
why you started it like and you got to
protect that that's yours because it's a
cost to me like I'm paying for you to be
here but then also at the same time you
know you give it time you let you you
hope it works because you want it to and
I think it's also like a few other
co-founders I know they say that it's a
pride thing they're like when you've got
staff you sometimes don't want to let
them go because it's like you feel like
you failed m but it's actually not that
like the bigger failure will be keeping
them for way too long yeah you got to
take the emotion out of it that was the
first one for me it's just you got to
particularly when you're early on and
it's like the first couple of hires you
you want them to work out don't you yeah
exactly like we're really lucky like the
team that we've got right now was so so
good we've got someone else is joining
in February and we're buzzing for that
because that person aligns with exactly
what we want did you do did you change
so one of the things that I did was I
really I changed the interview process
quite a bit when I learned from the the
second one so you're saying that you've
had to be really you know U like CL have
Clarity on that they align with the
things that you care about have you done
anything in the interview process or
changed it to really uncover if they
actually align with what you're looking
for I think we generally so the
interview process will be like whoever
finds them Chris or I will do like an
initial phone call then if that goes
well teams call and then if that goes
well in person and I think that speaking
to us both separately like if if I
interview someone and I like them then
they go to the next stage with Chris and
Chris isn't sure we probably won't
pursue it right because if you're not
100% invested in the interview then like
what are you doing like if they've not
impressed you then then like what why
would we pursue it um and I think each
one of the interviews that we've had
have got better and better nice in terms
of like the caliber so we're we have
such a high standard now because of the
people that we've got in the business
and what we expect from the interviews
like a couple of the guys that we've got
now they were so relaxed in the
interview we were like these guys are
like the they're just so like normal
which is hard to find like speaking to
hundreds of people who want to do
recruitment um how people that want to
do recruitment I know crazy don't let
your Tik Tok comment section see that
but I had one guy who was like I wanted
do pharmaceutical recruitment really I
was like okay why tell I said tell me
one thing that you've read in the news
that sort of interests you about the
pharmaceutical industry and he literally
said I don't know I was like you
literally could have said covid-19 and I
would have thought that better we would
carried it on yeah like anything like
what's wrong with you like red flag yeah
literally yeah um so it's kind of just
like yeah making sure that I don't know
it's it's very interviews that I do are
very conversational yeah fair I I do
think it's worth like if you're very
clear on what those things are you you
definitely want to think about you want
some like specific questions in there
that you feel un it cuz one of the
things that I added which I couldn't
believe I didn't do before but when I
was hling for the the sales role the
first person I hired it was very like
conversation and these things but then
when I learned from that the second time
around I got some advice on the
interview process and yeah in as part of
the interview process what they had to
do was some of the like tasks that they
were going to have to do in their role
so I actually got an opportunity to see
how they would approach writing in the
email how they would we did like a role
play to start the interview oh wow it
because what like when this person
started I was like oh my God they're
like so off or like and the the second
time round we had a phone call did all
the conversational stuff but then I just
did a task in between the face to face
where it was I want you to the this is
what our ideal customer profile looks
like I want you to find five companies
that you feel fit that and I want you to
identify one person in one of those
companies and I want you to write an
email that you think would um you know
uh get them curious about our solution
which I told them about and then in the
interview we then did a uh role playay
which was right I'm now going to at the
person that you emailed like let's play
out how you'd approach that that cool
yeah um and it was Unreal to like see
how they would approach it before we've
even like hired them no so the best
interview I ever had um it was a guy who
experienced in recruitment Dr desk um
Chris and I W on teams with him and then
he says contract recruitments easy oh
and I just looked at him I was like you
what what and he was like yeah like I
gave him the chance to think about what
he said and see if he'd like try and
sort of like explain it and he was like
yeah contract recruitment is easy and I
was like okay well let's look at your
Billings over the last 24 months you've
done two contract deals if contract
recruitment is so easy then why have you
not done more than two and he's oh it's
different for me and I was like yeah of
course it is like what are you talking
about like don't don't talk to someone
who's built their contract career in
that is a wild statement to say
literally I was like honestly it's a no
for me yeah fair so talk to us about
what what you excited about then so
we're you've you know two years in your
you're two years into the journey like
talk to us a bit about what you're
excited about going into year three yes
I think year three for us really will be
growth um so it'll be six in February I
think if we end if this time next year
are on 10 I'll be happy and I think our
us division is where we're going to
Channel A lot of efforts next year um us
is something that Chris has always been
passionate about and we've also got so
our first employee she's from United
States and she's starting to build out
that sort of division for us what
contract or perm perm nice um you to
think about doing contract there or
potentially I think it depends very much
on so us contract is completely
different with different laws and things
like that it's like it can differ per
state can't it yeah exactly um and I
think once my contract team is the best
in the UK then we'll look at what
geography we want to go to next but I'm
thinking Europe mainly because I've got
connections out there already time
difference isn't as bad um not so much
of a language barrier because most of
them most of the clients speak English
anyway um but yeah our us division on
the perm side is what we'll probably
develop next year um exciting so yeah
I'm buzzing for that party in the USA
let's go I think yeah look kudos to you
I think obviously you know think about
it let's not forget that you you did
send that message at 3:00 a.m. saying
I'm not sure I could do it and you're
now cuz I'm sure it's easy to forget
that that you felt like that right
you're now two years in like you know
whenever we speak you seem super
energetic I'm sure you're in enjoying it
most of the time it's hard but you're in
it right now you're you're building your
business and that's that's the really
great thing about our industry like you
can you work hard you can apply your
skills you can learn some of the things
that you're learning along the way yeah
but you know you're you're building a
business yeah I love it love it um well
thank you so much for coming on the Pod
thank you for having me